is Startalk I'm your host Neil deGrasse
Tyson your personal astrophysicist and I
got with me as always Chuck nice Chuck
hey Neil so we are live live oh my god
win what does it mean it means I get to
hold up a newspaper and it will have
today's date on it you still read
newspapers newspaper please I get to
hold up my tablet shows that we're live
okay and now we have to give them now we
have to give them proof of life so that
our so that we can get the money for our
victim anyway why are we doing this
YouTube lie yeah it's it's first it's to
sort of celebrate the fact that we get I
get it are you to present in the mail
finally what are we gonna get to see
what's in that thing finally I think so
yes we're gonna open it up but also we
want to I just want to say thank you to
our patreon members these are people who
basically actively subscribe to us by
giving us money each month this is a
higher level of participation that's and
we do things for them exclusive things
for them like they get their own cosmic
queries for example and there are other
things there's like a scale depending on
how much you put in and becomes a
fundamental buoyant force in what we do
to bring this this show to you and and
also I think some people don't know that
we have this sort of topical spin-off of
star talk yeah both star talk supports
edition that's right and you're my
co-host with Garry O'Reilly that's right
former footballer for footballer in
translate that Chuck that's a that's a
professional soccer player across the
Great Khan and a lot of actual athletes
and coaches and trainers and all of what
goes on in sports is such a big sports
edition is there so you can check that
out but anyway I want to open this kind
of open this now please
let us see there we go oh so so here's
what happens so if you have a youtube
channel as we do start or channel when
you hit these milestones these are these
are milestones in base 10 okay okay
tend to a power of some numbers so if
you hit ten thousand a hundred thousand
and we recently hit a million hit the
million million so what do you get what
do you get when you hit a million looks
heavy
[Music]
well you get a black piece of paper what
oh my god that's amazing
you're too kind whoa can you see that oh
that's really pretty
yeah focus yeah I can see yeah uh-huh
so I'll read it to you it says I present
it to Startalk for passing 1 million
subscribers and you press this and today
you go I was gonna say just you press
that and and you and you have 1 million
subscribers that's all it takes
that's all it takes you just press it
you press that button you get it
now that's very cold so we'll find a
place to hang this and so next next
target I guess and be 10 million 10
million there you go maybe now is it 10
so maybe you could put that right next
to your coronavirus containment field
that you have sitting behind ice to say
anything further about that device all
right on okay you're saying right yeah
just saying as long as it as long as
you're not coming to us from Wuhan I
think I'm nice and I'm in an undisclosed
safe house in the middle of nature hence
the the Beatles surround me yeah so
anyhow so so we're gonna we can do what
we do best and take some questions from
the audience
some have already rolled in and then we
can take some lines since this is live
and you got it all I haven't seen any of
them Chuck yeah yeah
and it's funny I love it because you
know I lifted them right off of the
YouTube site as you can see and they say
like 18 hours ago 12 hours ago it's kind
of cool yeah yeah yeah well when they
arrived yes yeah right from when it
arrived so this is smack dealer 1 he
says if a separate human colony was well
established on Mars what would likely be
the most valuable resource Mars could
trade with earth ooh
so kind of reminiscent of them a
television series called the expanse
except it's not Mars the humans that
move to Mars become far more advanced
because they're all like real science II
minded and then the ones left on earth
are just like you know Trump supporters
no I'm joking I'm joking
that was a joke the ones left on earth
you know they continued on in the path
that we Earthlings could have the
trajectory that we're on but then
there's a separate group of Earthlings
that go out to the Kuiper belt and
they're miners and so they're they're
actually bringing all the he says this I
immediately thought about that if we
were if there was a Mars earth - how
interesting would it be would Mars have
something to give to us ok so first of
all the camera book has mostly icy
objects icy bodies which is much less
used to us than heavy metals so you and
the asteroid belt is way closer and then
the Kuiper belt so what else it is the
asteroid belt
I said Kuiper belt a vast asteroid belt
get me started
yeah belt there in the asteroid belt
hence the mining operations because
they're grabbing these large craggy
floating boulders and drilling down into
them and pulling out all kinds of good
stuff
ok so here's the thing we don't yet know
the full depth profile of Mars and what
it contains and what's there there's
probably not oil deposits I'm guessing
oil on earth comes from dead vegetation
from from
millions of years ago so no but that's
what discovery is all about right but
who knew that earth had oil that you
could pull out of the ground and build
civilization on it and then have to get
rid of it later right so you just don't
know you just know that's a whole point
of exploration so so Mars it would be
interesting what I can imagine is you
can have inventive people there that use
the natural resources that are that are
common on the surface of Mars and do
something inventive with that and then
trade that and that way so it wouldn't
have to be only something that Mars has
it could be that Mars has the
intellectual capital that is the people
who went to Mars of are of a particular
variety of people who have so they took
their natural resource and made stuff
they pioneered chocolate and caulks
and the Swiss Army knife the top three
that know this sure that just they they
made precision timekeeping out of the
mountains this is a this is an expertise
that your culture brings that you then
put into commerce so I can imagine if we
are a multi-planet species that not
everybody's gonna be building the same
stuff and so whether or not there's a
natural resource that you would trade as
natural or which surely would still
happen it could be that you got people
directly had remembered a straight from
the asteroid belt if you get a metallic
asteroid that is a concentration of all
the heavy elements that we've cared
about in our civilization cadmium
platinum gold what else just named and
we're all the rare earth elements
yttrium all of these are in high supply
in these asteroids so it might be
whoever gets to last sue the asteroids
best then their commerce
is not only what they do on their planet
but their ability to to exploit the
resources to lism interplanetary
mercantilism that's what that is very
nice yeah very nice I love that word
mercantilist
all right that's what they dance what
made Venice and that's an Amsterdam and
All American tiles in the day the
mercantile yeah
Merchant of Venice merchants they didn't
say capitalist to Venice he said
merchants there Venice right that's
right Shakespeare is play of course all
right all right why don't you go okay
this is Kevin wait what were these
focused into any theme or is it just any
question about anything I don't see a
theme all right okay so here's what I'll
do and we discussed this in another
episode where it's not that I know the
answer to everything
but I'm I know some things about a lot
of things so if you ask me a question I
can answer I might give you something to
know about that that might still not
answer your question but gives you it's
still something to walk away with
all right so we'll call this one cosmic
queries something to know okay let's do
it
there you go Kevin Pahlavi or the vial
says this is the divine there's a two
L's in an e no no it's not it's not a
Lladro type deal those who don't for
whom this is their first cosmic queries
Chuck don't know how to pronounce
anybody's name no I do not I do not know
how to pronounce anyone's name and by
the way when I mispronounce your name
the great thing is you now have a new
name you can have from the government
our gallery galaxy in the shape of a
spiral and why do other galaxies have
other shapes
okay well most Germans the shape of a
galaxy most galaxies in the universe are
spirals so we in the club okay we are
not rare in this first of all second so
the two main things that's a great
question by the way and we call this the
spiral shape galaxy's spiral galaxies
all right because that's how we roll
Sagara galaxies a region of space you
fall in you don't come a black hole okay
like none black origin of space-time Big
Bang all right we are we're we fully
embrace one syllable communication with
each other okay
about a concavities word super jupiter
has a big red spot on its surface right
you don't we call it what Jupiter's red
spot hey you go that's not the only spot
wait the sun has spots and we draw them
sun spots okay yeah okay to that and now
back to this equation what should we
call this Neil
what should we call this it's spots on
the Sun so you have this huge gas cloud
and it begins to collapse all right and
because gravity that's the natural thing
gravity wants to do I talked about a gas
cloud larger than a galaxy that will
become a galaxy alright if the galaxy
has any kind of extra spin to it as it
collapses it spins faster okay you've
seen this on ice where ice skaters right
if they're spinning at all if they bring
in their hands they end up spinning
faster right but there's a basic feature
of physics it's called the conservation
of angular momentum but that's what
happens if you strike down you spin
faster if I weren't in a chair I would
do it physically and next time we have
to start talk live I'll do it start talk
live fact what we did it we one of those
as it as it get as it begins to shrink
it spins faster and faster and as it
spins faster that part of the galaxy has
a harder time making it into the middle
whereas the top and bottom just Falls in
so you get a nice big bulge in the
middle but the rest flattens to make
this disk okay
it's what happens when you spin pizza
dough it flattens okay and so if you
took Pillsbury Doughboy right and
started spinning him he flattened okay
Wow
hazardous activity Ferb exactly if you
were not a solid shape and if you throw
some chocolate chips on them and put
them in the oven
that's worse so so anyhow so so that's
right now these these galaxies have a
lot of gas in them and it's gas out of
which you make cloud a star
okay stars are gas and so you have all
this gas and here's what happens we
think that there is a shockwave is where
extra new stars are being made and so
it's the stellar nurseries that trace
the spiral pattern there's still stars
everywhere else
all right people carefully had spiral
galaxies this star is everywhere but
along these spiral edges that's where
you get very high mass high star
formation activity and so and galaxies
that don't rotate much at all
they don't flatten out and they forever
stay as these spherical elliptical
shapes and they're not making many stars
today you're not gonna find exploding
stars there which is the sign of newly
formed stars that have high mass that
becomes supernovae and black holes and
all the cool stuff so we live in a
really cool galaxy because you have a
lot of stuff going on nice so by the way
her name is Sasha Cohen that's not going
yes I said exact thanks for remembering
that yeah yeah very cool very cool I
love that alright so were you were you
first asking patreon questions no I was
not so ok also so in a normal cosmic
queries we were first section is
occupied by patriarch was Plus like I
said they get their own exclusive come
poster that's right
yeah just do their own cosmic queries a
command performance where you get to ask
whatever you want to kneel and that
happens once a month if you are a
patreon patron so go to
patreon.com/scishow pray do and support
us right now and and then if you're 10
dollars and above then you know we'll be
we can do this privately for you just
for you yeah yeah all right here we go
this is why don't we take a live
question all right what and Walford it
for having done that and if you haven't
done it yet what's stopping you just
asking right if you haven't subscribed
yet right right now now is the time now
is the time now it's the time if not now
when
right and not who you thought now win if
nah who you right all right all right
this is let's go to live from our
YouTube chat room and this is its rug
Joshi
sorry history if that's not right it is
right according to Chuck yeah yeah in
the truck reverse it's correct there you
go I like that Esther says this if light
has no mass why is it affected by
gravity
that's a brilliant question and because
you know gravity attracts mass right and
so if you got no mass why should you
care okay because according to you both
so the couple of ways out of that one
but let me give you the the cleanest the
cleanest explanation is gravity is not a
force on a mass gravity is the
distortion in the fabric of space and
time caused by any concentration of mass
and energy aha and so if you are moving
through space you are moving on a path
that the your speed plus the curvature
space requires of you and so if your
matter moving substantially less than
the speed of light you will curve in
towards the object if you're moving as a
concentration of mass so so light and we
say the light bends but if you are the
light I think you're going in a straight
Wow right so if you look along this
direction even if it curves down like
that
it'll it'll appear to you as that thing
down here is right in front of you
because you are traveling the shortest
distance between those two points and
it's a straight line to you step back
and you see the curvature in the fabric
of space so so there you have it another
way to think about it is equals
mc-squared energy and mass at and c
squared is the speed of light so energy
and mass are equivalent if you drive an
electric car let's say a Tesla and then
you fill it
put into the car than it did before you
put in the energy okay so that's the
equals mc-squared equation so you can
you can convert the energy of the photon
into a mass and then treat it as though
it had that mass and then follow the
equations there that's fourth so so
there you have that's why it's pretty
loud yes that's so cool so that's that's
why when you look at a black hole you
see the light around the black hole but
you're not really
that's not light from the black hole
it's like that was behind it that got
curved at that time where does the black
hole and the light here came up been
around and then it came out the other
side and you're over here watching it
and you saw something on the other side
of the black hole and that works in all
directions around the black hole so in
that famous photo of the black hole that
made headlines yeah several months back
what you saw is light surrounding the
black hole having come around it so you
see the shadow of the black hole in a
sense yeah
very very cool okay let's light so
that's like being affected by the force
of gravity nice yeah all right okay
lucid potato
okay lucid potato wants to know what are
your thoughts on nasa's recent remarks
of the possibility of parallel you've
conducted where they're looking for
particles from space these are called
cosmic rays they call rays but they're
actually high-energy particles and they
collide with the atmosphere and they
make a stream of other particles and you
can measure them and we've been doing
this for like since back in the the
since the early 19th century okay so
these particles are coming through well
okay this apparatus that's measuring
these particles found a particle come
from the opposite direction okay right
they didn't expect that there one
interpretation is that this particle is
in fact from another universe where time
moves backwards
and you're watching this particle travel
backwards through time uh-huh okay so it
had already passed you but you're saying
it moved backwards through the other
direction okay or there was a glitch in
their apparatus no 99 explanations you
can put into this before you're
compelled to have to say this is a
missile parallel universe moves
backwards and that particle happens to
be detected that's that's all I'm saying
so what makes headlines is the one that
gets the click that's the clickbait okay
if this is probably something wrong with
the apparatus or they made a mistake or
whatever that doesn't get the clicks so
I think on that level who's what's the
person's name what do you think lucid
potatoes on that level mr. potato not
you you are in almost every case if you
read the original scientific paper and
look at how they couched the the
explanations it will have nowhere near
the hyperbole of how the newspaper
article was written because scientists
are trained to be conservative in our
estimates so yeah but like you said that
is not a very good news story you know
could be a parallel universe
probably a malfunctioning I just did the
ranking I think you know if you can have
an extraordinary explanation for
something you better have extraordinary
confidence that the whole supply chain
of your of your experiment was working
that's all right cool I see here in the
chat that whoa okay rich you got another
one race hub what is hobby shop says
this it's a really cool question how is
the universe 92 billion light-years
across when the Big Bang happened only
14 billion years ago Wow
so okay so let me put some context in
that 92 billion light-years across
okay so you cannot get you the 90 or 46
right so no you can't see that because
their light has not reached you yet okay
we calculate that as the current size of
the universe based on the rate of
expansion from the Big Bang okay so
what's the farthest you can see the
farthest you can see is 14 billion
light-years away
okay that gal 12 13 billion like moxie
is 45 billion light-years away in this
instant if you could see everything all
at once that's where that couch is
that's why you would say the diameter of
the universe is 90 is 92 billion
light-years across
so the horizon is smaller than that
that's that's why that's how you get
those it's also saying is if if light is
time like the passage of time in order
for a light year you're talking about
time as well then how did you get so
many more light years in the totality
even though you're only seeing the
horizon so no so what you see is not all
that's out there that that's my only
point so so it'd be what's what would be
a good example of that let's say let's
say a turtle had a message on its back
okay Ned the universe just began okay
and you put it in st. Louis and have it
walk towards New York okay okay
it'll be a long while before that
happens about 45 billion years
I'll take the turtle 13 billion years to
get to you right okay but what has
happened to st. Louis that it's
expanding beyond that horizon it is
something it is and you be put in the
model the model the expansion of the
universe or
push that let's say beyond and that's
that's really where the that's really
what he the model could have been
different
ran it could have been even farther than
that I have a we modeled the expansion
of the universe and that's weird get
that where you have it so it's not about
the fourteen point eight billion light
years it's about the expansion yeah the
universe yes that's really what it's
about cool you got it and is that as
that model and also as model just by the
rate of the expansion of you see how
fast it was expensive early on and then
a little later and a little too so you
look at that expansion rate between then
and now
gotcha lad is still doing its own thing
but what is the gap so in other words
the moment that it put the light the
letter the letter is on the way but the
post office is still headlong you know
but I just want to get back into that
rhythm all right let's get back in the
rhythm
Sumerian says this congratulations
coming to us from YouTube
congratulations dr. Tyson on 1 million
subscribers hey Chuck that when the
James Webb telescope is finally in orbit
and operational what kind of discoveries
will expect to make and which discovery
are you most excited for ok excellent so
a false assumption was made that it
would just be in orbit like the Hubble
telescope this is going to be a million
miles on the other side of the Moon Wow
now we'll be orbiting the Earth but in a
way that is out of that distance ok so
it's not like astronauts if something
goes wrong with that telescope ain't
nobody going to fix it Wow it's not
going to be serviced is not going to
have hero astronauts replacing the
lenses or the detectors or the computer
chips
no-pros Willis saving us from an
asteroid again there's your reference
there so so that telescope here you go
most of the energy was high high energy
light emitted by these galaxies mostly
from the birth of brand-new high mass
stars a lot of blue light is coming from
them however that light has been moving
through an expanding universe and that
light has redshifted it is
become lower energy light so it shifted
from blue to go backwards through it so
it's what is it green and then orange
yeah yellow green and then red and then
infrared you go through the whole
spectrum it has shifted so much that the
principal light from those galaxies is
now in the infrared part of the spectrum
this telescope was conceived and
designed to observed redshifted light
from galaxies born at the beginning of
the universe oh it is brilliant wow that
is that is really brilliant
so you yes it's it's almost like a
little a little visual time machine to
go back and look at the near beginnings
and because we know we see originally we
were just discovering stuff with our
normal optical telescopes and it's like
okay is if there is it not I don't know
what am I looking at let me decode it
now we know what that light will look
like even though we have no date if
there are galaxies being born this
telescope will see them in the infrared
because we know what galaxies would look
like being born so it is the invocation
of very deep understanding of the
history of the universe and the
formation of stars and the formation of
galaxies to have the audacity to build a
telescope just to sneak in and observe
that in the way no other telescope has
done before Wow now because it's
sensitive to infrared you can also look
deep into gas clouds that are nearby
disks around the stars being formed so
it'll be hugely useful for nearby gas
clouds as well as the origin of the
universe itself James Webb Space
Telescope can't wait
yeah that's pretty exciting and it will
also be able to see predator so what are
nothing I'll be confront our seasoned
insides in the air you see what I did
there okay
yeah I feel like
okay yeah we read another movie it was a
walk around the block man what's your
total walk around three that was a walk
around the block okay
predator the movie right was an alien
who happens to be about the same size as
humans and walks on two legs has two
arms in a head and eyes nose and mouth
but he's from outer space yes you know
you make fun of much you make fun him he
speaks English and you this is to be
talk you school out the names all the
time I am pronouncing better than you
okay so I'm sure so he starred in the
movie they had some other sort of
muscled soldier types with very powerful
guns and it's they against predator and
predator you fun you got to see what
predator saw and predators saw in very
low res infrared images we have
detectors okay here we go back to okay I
love this question from extra-crispy
colonel he says this how plausible do
you think the idea is that it is
possible for light to reach around the
universe and reach us again for example
I've heard on the show from people like
Janna Levin yeah so you know you so it
needs a different kind of geometry and
but so the point is there exists a
geometry where the light will go out
from our universe curve in the curved
fabric of the entire universe come back
and you can see that light from this
direction and it would be our own galaxy
but the the shape of our universe is not
one that allows that but people have
posed that question and attempted to
answer that by looking at the birthday
photo of the universe this is the famous
Cosmic Microwave Background the CMB is a
it is a background of microwave light
so here's another redshift thing that
light started out as visible light like
the surface of the Sun that is very rich
in visible light and over the expansion
of the universe it has red shifted way
through came out the other side went
down through the infrared and it landed
in microwaves
that's how red shifted it got and so
that is a record of the structure of the
universe when that light was released
that's when the universe was about
380,000 years old very like that's a
baby picture right there
all right relative to the 14 billion
year age of the universe that we have
today so there exists shapes of the
universe where that could happen and but
we're not in one of them but it that's
an it would be a fun interesting
universe yeah that's very cool you know
we had well chuck was it one of our
other cosmic queries it might've been a
patreon cosmic query which someone
suggested can we set up a sequence of
mirrors in space and so you can see our
past and there's nothing preventing that
so if there was a perfect mirror 33
million light years away okay okay and
we took out our telescopes and looked at
that mirror we would see Earth from how
long ago 33 million years no wait 33
million light years away yes we'd see
earth now no [ __ ]
sure wait what am I missing [ __ ] don't
make me come in and slap you okay so
there's a mirror 33 million light years
away okay
Oh 66 thank you yeah I'm sorry thank you
I forgot about the mirror it's a mirror
at the mirror we're looking in the
mirror I miss mirror I missed that part
I missed the mirror goes out there and
it comes back so the light that we see
now is like the left earth 66 million
years ago okay and that's just on the
cusp of when the dinosaurs were taken
out by an asteroid and possibly other
natural forces
on earth like super volcanoes so so if
you had a series of mirrors you could in
principle see the history of the earth
you can see your own past yeah you have
to preset those up and they get back
here will work that part out you know
right so no think about it if you put a
mirror 33 million light years what you
have to travel there at the speed of
light we wait for you you come back 66
million years later now you'll only see
what earth look like when you left
not in our past because you can't see
into the past of when you first put up
the mirror and and this is less what
unless you can travel faster than light
right and wormhole will allow that by
the way I can't wait till we have
normals really right yeah well this this
is why we have to shore up Social
Security so so when you get back here to
still be here all right okay okay here
we go how about this one I like this how
are we doing on time I said I'd give
sound byte answers and I haven't been I
don't care they're good answers okay I
don't like your sound by the answers I'm
gonna be honest I mean they're all right
there we go for a sound bite um
the success arteries who wants to know
this if the universe is expanding and
galaxies are moving away from each other
how come the Milky Way will collide with
the Andromeda shouldn't they be moving
farther away from galaxies that are near
to ride the expansion of the universe
and that's true for our solar system
it's true for nearby galaxies that are
near by each other that's why we have
galaxies colliding all across the
universe these are galaxies that already
started near by each other now I got a
break sound byte mode and give you
something that will prevent you from
having restful sleep this evening uh-oh
here we go
okay you've heard of dark energy yes so
dark energy is a pressure in the vacuum
of space causing an acceleration in the
vacuum
then the more vacuum you have that is
the more the universe expands and the
more of this are the more of this dark
energy you have relative to gravity
because gravity is thinning okay as
things get far that you having a thinner
thinner and if you live in the vacuum of
space as dark energy you win and you not
only win you not only beat gravity your
rate of expansion becomes exponential Oh
a word we've heard a lot about in the
corona virus okay I've got my
containment vessel here but okay so
calculations show that in ten to the
twenty two years from now okay the
expansion that the accelerated expansion
will be so severe that we'll have what's
called the big rip oh yeah that happened
to me once on stage it was oh my god so
embarrassing you know you've got to go
on with the show maybe you know you
can't plan it to the host star and in a
galaxy and nearby gods even those will
not be able to stay together and
galaxies that would have collided would
get ripped apart then it starts
stripping planets from their host solar
systems their star systems then it
begins ripping matter apart okay this is
the big rip and this this accelerates
okay so the scenario I'm describing
happens fast after you've waited that
much time because the the the the power
of this rip okay manifests on large
scales first and then it's happening so
much that the very fabric of space
itself feels that even on the small
scales and so it starts ripping apart
solar system ripping apart matter then
it rips apart atoms then game over did
it okay game over and then might even
rip apart the particles themselves oh
that's just terrible the big rip so this
person wants to galaxies to spread apart
be careful what you wish for
wow that's auditor there you go buddy
you opened a whole
can of galaxies dinya holy moly that's
it that's a really depressing thought
because just think about it just it just
imagine that think that beginning to
happen yeah around you oh yeah that's
the fan oh snap it's like that's just
terrible that's terrible yeah okay here
we go
Santos save some people you didn't do
that that's yeah see the universe
doesn't even have as much compassion is
absolute zero Cole okay here we go this
is hunter Coleman who catches birds
birds so cool in fact I think shiny
Night Live had a had a skin about that
about black nerds yeah yeah in the
street I'll hang out on the street I
didn't I know that and you know it's
funny the once time in life when I'm
home to watch Saturday Night Live
because I'm not allowed to go out
because I'm never home on Saturday
nights always working and there's no
Saturday I hey we got a few in the
carnival and a few Corona first episode
okay I hope Coleman wants to know this
could the fourth dimension be holding
together the fabric of space the one
that we just talked about ripping all
apart for instance in our 2d dimension
being stuck on a flat surface that our
3d world makes up and holds together is
space the flat surface for yeah it could
be but I don't require I don't think it
requires higher dimensions to contain us
it could just be that our life in three
spatial dimensions one time dimension is
the flat surface for the five six seven
additional beings but not doesn't
necessitate that that is that that
contains us holding us right right and I
would say they would pity us for living
in a mere four dimensions Wow as we
would pity anyone that exists only and
drawn in a sheet of paper into now yes
so true yeah all right keep going
lightning around five minutes go here we
go
nebula man six thousand sixty thousand
seven says would be would it be possible
to make your own man-made wormhole is it
ever possible yeah so so we know how to
make a wormhole oh no no sorry we know
the mathematics you gave up the tapes
Neil it's too late too late no we don't
know how to make a mantel no I probably
I mean a worm oh I promise we don't know
how but on paper we can describe it but
it turns out to configure matter and
energy to open the hole it makes a very
unstable conduit and so we don't know
how to keep it propped open so that if
you step in it then it would collapse
around you and no telling what that
looks like
if it collapses around you uh-huh and I
have to tell this I said this probably
the fifth time I've said it on Startalk
I was in Charlotte Airport and going
from a big plane to a little plane I
swear there's three miles to walk that
distance and there's early in the days
of Twitter and I thought I was cute I
tweeted about that and I said you know I
can't wait for when we had wormholes
that when all gates are adjacent to one
another that be the name awesome Airport
right you just sort of step and then
you're there but if someone replied dr.
Tyson if we have wormholes you don't
need air force but the wormhole is the
airport see you know something all right
all right here we go you've got a couple
more yeah we go here we go
this is Robin sage who wants to know
this how recent is the information our
telescopes giving us about anything up
there since the light is a lot in the
past
how are x-ray and other telescopes or
even radio signals doing in this context
of bringing us information yeah so we
speak of things in the present just
because it's easier in the same way you
speak of the Sun rising even though
earth is rotating such that the Sun
comes in view above your local horizon
it's easier to say the Sun rose okay in
astrophysics is easier to say all we
observed the star blow up yesterday or
this thing happened two days ago
well it happened way longer ago than
that and the light is just reaching us
it just comes very clumsy to say that we
have no way of knowing anything in the
present moment because it takes light
time to reach us
you can't even know what the Sun is
doing right now if Thanos came in and
removed this idea there was no Sun there
so we see things not as they are but as
they once were and the farther away it
is the more ago it once was wow I would
just stuck with that so in a way
everything we see in the universe is
kind of like a ghost
it's all yesterday's news and in fact
there's an Italian movie called la
correspondence
la Souris by the Benza of course what
the correspond correspondents Jeremy
Irons starred in it as an astrophysicist
and he had a terminal illness and he had
a love interest and he would send her
letters okay but she didn't know he was
dying and I think it was a overseas or
whatever but he would send her letters
so that after he died she would still
get letters like stars that might have
died long ago but still sends you their
love it's kind of cruel a man who was it
no it was an astrophysics love story
yeah like I said it's kind of cruel hi
one more how about this one more okay
Archer twelve 123,000 says this do you
believe in life on other planets yes
it's not about belief is is there
evidence there's no evidence yet
what have we made of life on Earth the
most common ingredients in the universe
is what life is made of and I've said
before if we were made of like some
isotope of bismuth you would have good
argument to say hey life is special well
life is rare life is it we made a
hydrogen oxygen carbon nitrogen this
stuff is the top four ingredients in the
entire universe
so as we look for life just because we
haven't found it yet absence of evidence
is not
of absence okay so and by the way how
much of the universe have we looked at
we got quote Jill tarter from the SETI
Institute Jill tarter says based on how
much we've looked in the universe for
life so far to declare that there is no
life would be like going to the ocean
with a cup of water with a empty glass
glass glass and you scoop up some water
and look at huh there's no whales or
don't fish at all right is it uh that's
how much is how much of the ocean you've
looked at by scooping up a glass that's
how much of the what we call parameter
space of life in our galaxy that we have
studied that we have observed so
restricted by time restricted by
frequency
all these factors combined is like
dipping a cup in the ocean so just
because I we haven't found it doesn't
mean every one of my people actual
physics has very high confidence to look
for it on the expectation that one day
we will find it the real test is and the
scary and tantalizing part is could
there be intelligent life out there and
if there is is it more intelligent than
we are would we even know it if we found
it because as we've said one thing is
for sure there is no sign of intelligent
life on earth ah I think we got to stop
it there
yeah damn that's a shame this was fun
yeah yeah and just a couple of things
since this is live I do might as well
say next Tuesday we we post the next
episode of Startalk sports edition and
that's where I interview Sophia the AI
robot yes dad that's that's Sophia she's
got like facial expressions a little
creepy yeah yeah she talks and you know
yeah I like I'm creepy though so what
sorry that one was not the sports
edition that's just ran out of stores I
thought we're talking what role a I
would play the artificial intelligence
would play in helping us understand the
corona virus because what good is AI
unless it could be
our servant right to help us so yes so
real it's like no you don't want to be a
server you want to be like one of us all
right and so that's it's really creepy
weird fun interesting tantalizing so
that's next Tuesday on regular regular
Startalk and every other Friday we
release the sports edition so that get
out if you're a sports fan at all I
think you'll love it and so there it is
cool so we've done it again thank you
all for this plaque Thank You YouTube
the plastic yeah
it's gold look at that oh yeah mine from
an asteroid they told me ah I just put
finger prints on yeah it's very cool
though yeah alright so thank you all and
if you haven't subscribed there's a
button push it and subscribe to this
show
alright and again we welcome any and all
patreon members your you're part of our
lifeblood so Chuck always good to have
you always a Beall deGrasse Tyson your
personal astrophysicist as always
bidding you especially in the corona
verse to keep looking up signing off